hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
rachel shabby and leader writer at the
daily telegraph tim stanley there they
are so let's see what's on some of those
front pages the observer leads on the
prime minister's surprise visit to kiev
today to meet the ukrainian president
where he pledged to send 120 armored
vehicles to help counter russia's
military offensive
it comes as nato reveals plans to deploy
a permanent full-scale military force on
its border that's on the front of the
sunday telegraph
the sunday express echoes president
zelinski's words to boris johnson in its
headline welcome to kiev my friend the
times leads on rishi sonak's wife
stating that sonic has moved his family
out of downing street following this
week's story and this is the sunday bill
it covers the incredible story of a war
veteran who drove three 3000 miles to
help his pregnant daughter-in-law in
ukraine
the mirror alleges that the coronation
street actor simon gregson was
questioned by police outside a pub near
the grand national racecourse
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discuss them
and as i was saying we're joined tonight
by rachel shabby and tim stanley rachel
and tim thanks a lot for joining us so
big news boris johnson in kiev rachel do
you want us to give do you want to give
us your reaction to that
yeah this is um it's a really powerful
story actually i'm not a huge fan of
boris johnson as i may have mentioned
once or twice but you know credit where
it's due
this is an incredible move um the
visuals on it the images coming out of
uh boris johnson meeting with ukrainian
president zolensky and walking through
the streets of kiev are just incredibly
powerful defiant bold it's a real show
of solidarity and the statements that
boris johnson made on that trip echoed
that solidarity but it has to be said as
well but it's not just the visual here
uh boris johnson in the uk is credited
by the ukrainian president and the wider
population for its efforts and support
for ukraine particularly in the sort of
military hardware uh that has been
supplied to the nation uh as it defends
itself against this horrific uh illegal
invasion from russia and that does seem
to be something that is echoed amongst
the wider um ukrainian population as
well that's something that british
journalists pick up on as they report
from that country um but there this was
a a closely kept secret apparently this
this trip um and i think the images that
it has produced are incredibly powerful
yeah i think we all found out about it
because of a tweet didn't we um tim
what do you think about it and i want to
look at something the prime minister
said he said ukrainians defied the odds
and pushed back russian forces from the
gates of kiev achieving the greatest
feat of arms of the 21st century
do you think that that is actually
what's happened here
i don't know it's far too early to say
one thing that the trip itself suggests
is that kiev is a little more secure
than it was and it does look as though
putin has pulled back uh he has shuffled
his military and he wishes to focus
instead upon capturing more air more
ground in the don gas region
so there there is reason to hope
but
i i think we should probably assume
russia is not going to give in but it's
going to continue a war of attrition uh
this new general who's come in is
notorious for bombing aleppo into
submission we should we should assume
that this is a long fight
and the question is what are the
conditions for a ceasefire what are
what what looks like winning and what
looks like losing i'm not quite sure
what the answer is to that um right now
britain keeps reasserting that putin
must lose well what does that mean apart
from pulling his troops out of the
country does it mean surrendering any
kind of russian presidents in the
breakaway parts of the eastern
part of ukraine does it mean giving up
crimea what does putin losing look like
so i'm not quite sure yet what the terms
for victory or defeat actually are
rachel what do you think i can see you
nodding there
yeah i think i think that tim's
absolutely right it really is unclear
um what the terms of the end will be or
indeed when it will come
um i think what has transpired over the
last few weeks as we've seen russians
russia's increasingly
horrific
attacks on ukraine and some of the
images and stories that have come out
over the last few weeks have been just
absolutely
grotesque um in their savagery but what
what we've seen over the last few weeks
is is number one that ukraine has been
able to
uh show much better uh resistance to
this horrific invasion that perhaps was
expected initially
um
not just because its military is capable
and well equipped but also because its
civilians are rising up um to defend the
country but also secondly that russia
isn't as good
militarily and in terms of strategy as
we perhaps thought it might be um it's
clunky
it's making mistakes um its soldiers are
you know conscripts who are young and
uninformed and not particularly
experienced um and so those two factors
have changed the dynamics on the ground
but that being said none of that takes
away from the fact that this is a
overwhelming use of force
um in an entirely illegal invasion that
is having absolutely devastating
consequences on ukraine using the same
sort of besiege
starve and terrorize uh population
strategies that actually we saw russia
using in in syria uh a few years ago
exactly and that is tim you also
mentioned syria that is the worry isn't
it that perhaps the worst is
yet to come and when this second
offensive the second wave starts that
we'll see
putin use even more of what he has tim
do you think
that possibly the only positive or one
of the very few positives is what the
sunday telegraph have
really honed in on and that
there will be this full-scale nato
military force to defend the borders and
that
even though putin obviously did not want
this to happen nato has never been so
united
hmm i should add one positive of course
as rachel has suggested is that ukraine
has really gained a sense of itself in
the course of this fight it's not just
ukraine has held because of the flow of
arms and money it's also because the
ukrainian people put up a far stronger
resistance than putin or perhaps many
outsiders would have suggested but
another positive
another positive outcome as you say is
that the west is now more united and
more clear-sighted about the dangers
posed both by russia and also china than
it was before we're starting to see uh
sanctions we're starting to see the west
decouple from the russian energy market
and in an interview with the telegraph
jen stoltenberg the secretary general of
the nato tells us that nato is united
that it recognizes the challenge has
changed and that is now going to shift
dramatically
away from what is called a trip wire
strategy whereby nato would station a
few troops along the russian border so
that if russia attacked a member state
that would trigger nato's response that
strategy is now going to be replaced by
a strategy of deterrence
or
or defense in other words that nato will
actually put an army on the russian
border capable of repelling the russians
that's a dramatic change in strategy and
of course the only way it can be done is
if nato members spend a lot more on
defense and increase other than their
number of soldiers and military hardware
etc so stoltenberg is trying to
encourage members now not just to hit
the target of spending two percent of
your gdp on defense but actually going
above that target which by the way if
they do that countries will start to
leave britain behind
for instance germany has recently agreed
to increase its defense spending to two
percent and because germany has a larger
economy than britain's that means that
it's going to actually excel in terms of
defence spending what britain is
currently spending and we are actually
projected right now to cut the number of
troops where our raf is lacking a
certain number of fast jets the navy is
lacking a certain number of battle-ready
warships so in other words there's
probably going to be a new arms race i'm
not sure that's a good thing necessarily
because you know frankly arms races are
horrific waste of of money and resources
but it's probably a necessary thing and
as you suggest
it's it's an unforeseen consequence of
putin's actions he thought ukraine would
surrender he thought the west as it did
in 2014 would take minimal action
instead you're seeing them that you're
seeing the beginnings of a second cold
war
i'm just going to ask rachel given what
we've seen in kramatowski yes yesterday
those horrific pictures and stories
coming out of butcher and other areas do
you think it's enough do you think that
morally it's enough that nato is going
to you know spend a huge amount and put
a force on its borders do you not think
that perhaps now the time has come in
for us to look up to go in and look
after the civilians of this country
you know that that that is a really
that's quite a loaded question i mean
morally of course all of us look at
these images with absolute revulsion um
the horrors that have been rained down
on the people of ukraine are just
absolutely horrendous and unimaginable
um
the the conversation amongst uh nato
countries and you know this this
interview the telegraph interview with
the nato chief comes a couple of days
after uh
nato countries uh foreign ministers plus
ukraine got together to discuss what to
do and it's absolutely correct that the
unintended consequence of this war has
been to
revamp and re-boost uh nato with some
other countries such as sweden and
finland now wanting to join as well but
there is a very big difference between
being a defensive operation and an
offensive operation and i think nato is
very very careful is trying to be
careful
to maintain that line on the defensive
side because the offensive line would
tip it into
a a much greater
war we would be dragged into
actually another cold war and that that
would be a completely
different uh order of things entirely
especially when we're dealing with with
a nuclear country
indeed and the ukrainian people continue
to pay that cost um
rachel and tim we're gonna take a quick
break but we'll come back
because coming up the telegraph reports
that an unexpected poll has said the
majority of young people would back
marine le pen in the french elections
against emmanuel macron at the moment
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me again at the journalist
and although rachel shabby and leader
writer at the daily telegraph tim
stanley hello again to you both we kept
at ukraine in the first half let's move
on now let's bring up the front of the
observer and tim um why don't you talk
us through rishi sunax and his hopes of
becoming pm does he still have any
this has been his week from hell
after the revelation that his wife was
uh non-domiciled uh and then followed by
uh the revelation that he had a green
card in the u.s
he's really been politically shaken by
this uh his wife has now moved out of
number 11 taking the two daughters with
them he will continue to work above the
shop but will commute at weekends to
their house in west london this is
highly unusual for someone to move out
of of downing street while they're still
employed in it
and so many people are saying that the
man who once seemed most likely to take
over his pm uh partly because of the
rave reviews he got for his handling of
the pandemic particularly
furlough
it now looks as though his star is is
coming crashing down into the sea
and i think the reason why he might be
brought down over this why he might
either have to resign or choose to
resign because he wishes to protect the
privacy of himself and his family
is because the british by and large will
forgive scandals related to sex and
personal morality
they can't stand the rich
and it's not i mean rachel will disagree
i know this isn't just a question about
his private wealth it's about how it's
handled and it's about conflicts of
interest nonetheless i do think that
money scandals cut through in ways that
sex and personal scandals don't and
that's partly because people right now
are personally financially suffering
partly as a consequence of government
policy rishi sunak would say that the
policies he's implementing like raising
national insurance are things forced
upon him by the pandemic nonetheless
whatever whether what he was doing was
legal or not whether in you privately
think it was ethical or not i'm gonna
jump into him because we've got half a
minute so let's have break let's um give
rachel a say it's true it seems true
what tim says they can't stand the rich
i think wealth is fine but abusing your
wealth and then having one rule for the
wealthy and one rule for the other for
everyone else is a completely different
thing and that's what's been so
gobsmacking
about rishi sunak and his green card
status and his wife's tax affairs it's
just extraordinary that the man who's
imposing such punitive uh tax rises on
us we're gonna have to believe in that
i'm sorry we'll leave it at
extraordinary shall we but um timber
rachel we'll see you in the next half
hour thank you